2 is the correct solution set. Fantastic work if you figured that one out. We
want to start out by finding the LCD for these three fractions. Since this is a
quadratic trinomial, we should factor it first to determine the LCD. This
denominator factors to x minus 3 times x minus 4. Since we have an equation, we
can multiply each term by the same factor. This keeps our equation balanced.
When we multiply through by the LCD, we'll get 1 times x minus 4, minus 4 times
x minus 3, which equals x. We distribute the negative 4 to get negative 4 x and
positive 12. Next we combine all like terms to get negative 3 x plus 8 equals x.
To solve this part we want to get our variables on one side of the equation and
our constants on the other. This is why we add positive 3 x to each side. And
finally dividing both sides by 4 we'll get x is equal to 2. Our solution set. We
know x cannot equal positive 3 and x cannot equal positive 4. These are excluded
values. We check our solution set against these to be sure this is correct.
Otherwise it, we would have no solution.